and by the way if you watch scarface
today it went from being a drama to
becoming a comedy
does that ever happen to you like after
20 years a movie goes from a drama to a
comedy
you know it was on one of those spike
with the [__] you know when they
changed the words around you know
you [__] fly you know whatever the
[__]
and this is a great scene watch this
this is a [__] great scene
and you've watched the movie a thousand
times and missed this
he's in his room it's towards the end
the colombians are coming
and he's cutting the coke with his hands
or something right and all of a sudden
he sits back he does
no he sticks his face in the pile and he
sits back and he looks around the room
and goes
all right i gotta get organized
that should be a commercial for a.d.d
right there like
i gotta get organized [__] great if
you watch it you gotta think of me next
time you see it
so we leave there and i'm like [__] i
had like two thousand dollars and i had
all these diamonds and all this jewelry
and this hash
what did i do i go you know what i want
to go straight i really wanted to go
straight i go
i'm gonna [__] try it i'm gonna get a
job so i got my buddies my buddy got me
a job bartending
and night and i had to go to the
american bartending institute
and in the daytime i got a job at a
warehouse i got a union warehouse job
so i figured if i'd work all the time
i'd keep my nose clean i wouldn't get in
trouble
and i work and i had two days off a week
and we would snort those whole [__]
two days
we would get like ten eight balls and go
to my friend's house and a keg of beer
and we put scarface on
and we try to figure out when he stabbed
him in the [__] detention center
what he would say and we couldn't figure
out because we were so coked up
you know now i figured out when i
watched it on spike last week
after 20 years like for the friend
you're [__] but in those days we'd be
watching and we're wearing the
what'd he say
i don't know what he said i don't know
let's rewind it and we rewind that
so it started as a two day [__] a
week thing
like that's it i would just do blow on
friday night with my girlfriend we get
all coked up and [__] i eat [__] and
get all creepy and [__]
and you didn't get that dick then that
was 84. the coke didn't give you a dead
dick your dick used to get [__] hard
your hips would move and you
and uh you know first i lost the day job
because i couldn't you know stick get up
to go to the [__] day job i'd bartend
until one
and i'd snort till six why go to work at
eight that's not gonna happen
so i lost a day job first that was like
may and
and i had this apartment i got my life
together it was beautiful
and i remember that when i got the
apartment it was [__] gorgeous i had
furniture and [__]
you know every month the apartment got
[__] up and more [__] up
like the shower curtain broke so i said
[__] a shower curtain
i just take a shower just like that and
every time i take a shower the kitchen
would [__] flood so
i mean it was one of those deals where i
just and when you're addicted to when
you start getting addicted to blow
you overlook things like [__] it leave
that towel there so the towel would
stink it was just
so pretty much i lost my day job and i
just thought and then the night nut job
was paying me great
let me take you guys back to give you a
little read here my mother had died in
this is 84. and that was just like uh
i tell i talk a lot of [__] and one
story i don't tell is i always tell
people i raised myself which i really
did but
uh when my mother came from cuba she
came together with this girl
and the girl had been married and moved
to chicago
so my mother went to new york and these
two women my mother and this girl
stayed in contact something happened she
married some dude they ran into
hard times after a year and she started
hooking and she called my mother in new
york and told her what happened
and my mother and my dad came from new
york and pulled her out of chicago away
from the abusive husband
so she always felt like she owed my mom
she was like a distant cousin
and uh she moved to new york and my
mother helped her out and then whatever
when when i was a kid before my mom went
out in the daytime we'd always stop this
ladies and gentle
and she lived on 113th and fifth avenue
this is the mouth of central park the
beginning of spanish harlem
this was a shoot-em-up type of
neighborhood she lived over a [__]
bodega
but she was like a multi-millionaire
from selling heroin all those years
and i didn't [__] know this my mother
would take me up there like that's not
where she lived it was her spot
but she lived like [__] a long island
out there with white people
dressing in white and smoking cigarettes
and [__] i mean this lady was a bad
[__] and i didn't know at the
time i didn't know what she did
i'd go over there and she'd give me like
20 bucks and i kiss her
and then you know i got to meet as i got
older older i get to be about 15. my
mother loses the bar she would come over
a lot to see my mom then
and always give my mom money and help
her out when my mother died
that morning the first person i called
was the writer i didn't know who to call
i called her i go to zarada my mother
died
she said i'll be over there in 10
minutes she came over and she took care
of everything you know she took care of
me
and the last night the wake she i was
sitting there looking at the cask and
she came over
and she was saying something to my
mother in the casket and i'm like this
lady's [__] crazy
you know maybe she's doing her own
powder i didn't know she sold
heroin at the time i just thought she
partied with my mother they used to get
drunk and she didn't talk [__]
so uh afterward that next day at the
funeral at the
burial she came over and she goes i made
a promise to your mother i was gonna
take k in the casket
in her casket i made her a promise that
i would take care of you
so whatever i'm gonna take care of you
i'm gonna help you out whatever you need
and i was like whatever you know
and sure enough this [__] stayed at the
house with me for like two weeks and
then she went back to new york but every
sunday she would come over
take a cab from 113th street to jersey
a [__] cab was like 200 each way this
crazy [__]
i'd meet her at a bar and we have a few
drinks her
and her son and her husband or boyfriend
whatever he was and we go down to the
funeral
she'd [__] drink at the funeral at
the cemetery put a few bumps of coke on
the [__] grave this lady was the real
deal
then she light up a [__] joint and
blow it at the [__] on the rock
and then she and then she'd [__]
sprinkle coke on the rock and leave the
joint there burning
and put like a drink for her whiskey
this chick was a [__]
and every time she go like it was two
years after she died i wouldn't cry but
she would still cry
this was her sister and she would give
me like 200 bucks
and like you know weed i would always
say bring me weed from harlem and she
would bring me like a little nickel bag
in those days
and she would ask me you don't do coke
or drugs and i would always lie to him
no no
no no one day i got into a bind and i
called off for money she goes come on
over
and when i went over i seen the coke
scales and [__] and i said you know
maybe i could sell some coke for you
once in a while
and she like looked at me where she goes
you know your mom i don't know i'm like
oh no seriously
my friends are gonna buy it anyway let
me [__] sell it
so she would give it to me from time to
time and i wouldn't sell it i would
snort it you know [__] who
you know you're the [__] you gonna kid i
and she would bring it to him every week
she called me how much do you want i go
bring me an eight ball
and instead of giving me cash she'd give
me the eight ball and i tell i'd sell it
but i just [__] do it you know
but she was there for me guys it's
really weird once
i had an uncle and i had a godfather and
i had a stepfather
and they weren't there for me but this
lady was always there for me
and it continued even when i went to
colorado i would call her every weekend
from colorado
and tell her i loved i mean i was always
in touch with her